Herschel Walker uh held some sort of a
press conference yesterday whenever he
does this it's a very very bad idea and
during this press conference he denies
yet another abortion claim remember a
second woman has come forward saying he
urged me to get an abortion he paid for
it I didn't want to do it after going to
the clinic he went back with me the next
day to make sure that I got that
abortion
um Herschel Walker denies it never
particularly credibly and then also says
he didn't kill JFK kind of making light
or making fun of the mere allegation
here as it is as if it would be
equivalent to accusing him of killing
JFK and you see in the background over
Walker's left shoulder if you're
watching that's Republican senator
Lindsey Graham we'll get to him and his
role in all of this in a moment Lindsay
just laughs at the entire thing
well I'm going to say right now you know
guys I'm done with this foolishness I've
already told people this is a line I'm
not gonna entertain and continue to
carry a lie alone and I also want to let
you know I didn't kill JFK at right now
Lindsay really liked that one I didn't
kill JFK either
Center one and he got crushed at that
debate now the Democrats are doing say
whatever they by the way Walker is
saying that he crushed Warnock at the
debate where Walker pulled out a fake
badge
to win this party when it's a seat but I
want them to know they don't know
Herschel Walker
they don't know that uh I'm from
Wrightsville Georgia and I'm going to
win this seat I told him when I got in
this race I'm going to win it and they
now see that I am going to win it so
you guys know that it's right here that
right now
I'm winning this seat
so I I think that Senator we're not
saying you're not like me too hot does
it
this this of course has nothing to do
with Warnock this has to do with now
multiple women who accuse Herschel
Walker of the exact same thing foreign
woman to have an abortion
so I've seen this movie before folks I
remember the Kavanaugh storyline really
well yeah Lindsey Graham is completely
pathetic and again all of the denials
are really not very credible here is one
from Fox News yesterday where Brett
Baier asks Herschel Walker are you
saying you don't even know the person
making the allegations and Walker simply
says it's a lie not a very strong denial
and remember this is how it started with
the first woman with the first woman
Walker was asked do you even acknowledge
knowing the woman and he said I have no
idea and then it was well yes I do know
the woman well yes uh I did send her the
money well yes I do have a kid with a
woman but I never urged her to get an
abortion so this is this is his denial
you tell me how credible this is
all right well this was Gloria Allred
came forward with this client you're
saying you don't know this person
what I'm saying is this is a lot
[Laughter]
well that's a different question
I've said it once and I've moved on my
campaign he said it once about a
different woman moved on because we're
worried about what the Georgia people
are talking about yeah uh not
particularly convincing denials but then
maybe the wackiest part of this entire
thing was when Lindsey Graham got
involved